let's go to our next caller why don't we
try the 702 area code I like the idea of
going to 702 and if you're with us
caller from 702 jump right in tell me
what's on your mind
hey David thanks my second time calling
I'm not on the speakerphone this time so
I'm good it sounds like you are but I
was like I'm glad you're not okay so I
actually had a quick question a little
bit of a story so on my facebook I was
scrolling through and one of my close
friends
he is a major Republican supporter and
he was posting some face of some
ballsacks right like about how white
people don't commit crimes in the United
States all like you know just extremely
incorrect information right and so I
went through the hassle of having an
argument with him and you know on
Facebook of course and saying hey the
information you're posting is not
correct those stats are completely fake
yeah and I had discussion with other
couple friends was saying should I do
that or shouldn't and I wanted to get
your perspective on that if you're doing
it for fun then I would say have at it
Hoss if you're doing it to try to change
people's minds I would suggest that you
put the time you spend doing that into
some other kind of activism maybe
getting people to vote in the 2018
midterms or something else because I
think as an exercise of curiosity or
entertainment it's totally fine but I
don't think you're really going to
impact policy by changing the minds of
people like that and I definitely agree
with you but I see also as well too that
when someone does something where they
post something on Facebook or Twitter or
where it is and they don't have an
opposing force that tells them hey this
is incorrect information you need to get
your policy straight right then I feel
like you know there's a
misrepresentation of the fact that
someone who posts something that
terrorists are always you know Muslim or
you know there can't be white people
terrorists and there's no opposition to
that then it becomes more accepted as
the way I feel sure no I think that's a
good point it's good for them to know
that there are dissenting views and and
but again I think if the it depends on
what your goal is and I totally get that
and also it could be more for the third
party people that see the exchange it
might be the people who are maybe less
informed than that guy
who are if if they see that there's
someone else pushing back they might
actually be thinking to themselves oh
well I'm glad to know that there's
another view here if that makes sense
yeah did you find that out do you know
that or is he like a normal internet guy
well so it was a couple different things
because he went on a tear that day and
he decided to post about how there's no
white what's called terrace and also uh
drinking all climate change in law he
had two things on that so on the one
that climate change is a lie he
basically refuted every single like
document I put up but a friend of mine
who was also in the exchange since all
exchanges says hey I didn't know that
there was so much information on that so
ever since then I've always tried to
clarify for people who post you know and
I'm not one for opinion right like hey
if you don't want you know to be gay
then hey you don't have to be gay but if
you say gay people were the reason why
you know there's child molestation that
I feel like you know that's an extremely
incorrect statement and I have to
correct that sure alright listen hey
you're doing something interesting it's
sort of up to you in the end whether you
think it's a good use of your time but
but electorally at least I think that
it's it's not but certainly I've been
party to a Facebook debater or - time
time and again I appreciate the call
thanks so much for calling and thanks to
everybody who called in we will take
calls again that I promise you and
thanks to everybody I didn't get to also
we had dozens and dozens of people
holding and the calls are getting very
popular but we can't get to everybody is
the sad reality